ah good evening and welcome to planning
West Committee
I'm just encouraged I'm the chair in
front of me are the other counselors who
are members of the committee and either
side of me are officers of the council
who will help us make our decisions
tonight and if I can ask them to
introduce themselves
Caroline Nash committee administrator
Ross chambers legal services I'm the
planning manager in my role as an
impartial adviser to the committee I can
clarify any planning issues that arise
doing so unbound by the code of
Professional Conduct of the Royal Town
Planning Institute and planning
committee members not bound by the case
offices recommendation Louise Coleman
Senior Planner planning officer Steve
Flaherty planning officer so item 1 on
the agenda apologies of absence
Javan apologies for see from cancer
Richards for him counselor brain is
substituting cancer for do for him
cancer fielding is substituting and also
from cancer Molly Giles we thank you for
substituting counselors minutes of the
meeting of 17th of October agreed lovely
thanks I'll sign those later and so we
get on to our planning applications I
would remote remind members of the
audience that this is open to the public
and members of the public who have
registered to speak will speak but if we
keep it to that
I cannot take comments from the audience
if you will
so the first Oh actually I haven't got
it down here I've missed it disclosures
of interest
some of this someone is calling you to
remind you about one of your disclosures
of interest in think it's max yeah so I
have I have interests on item item 6
which is 1602 233 lamb to the rear of
Littlewood green I've made a comment
against that so I won't sit in on that
and also I know the applicants at then
item 7 1802 131 old post office some
born so I won't sit on on that and this
committee will will choose another chair
for those items when I sit out
councillor Barnes have you got a an
interest in one okay
sorry item for application Oh 196 for Oh
crowd cheering tannoy ease please Thank
You chair the application site is
identified by black dot and map and it's
located on a area of land situated to
the south east of teddington village
outline application so planning
permission for the erection of sixty
dwellings has already been granted and
Planning Commission 15 4-stroke 0 2 0 5
7 o UT o UT and means of access was a
matter that was considered at that stage
a single vehicle access point is
proposed which is off Oak Road which is
here and and that was a matter under
consideration as part of that
application the application before
members this evening therefore is is for
reserved matters with appearance
landscape layout and scale to be
considered the site which is identified
by the red line on plan o joins existing
residential developments on the western
boundary a sheltered housing site sorry
my cursor is located opposite the
northern boundary which is known as
Margaret Court and the home guard Club
is located to the northwest and a new
housing development hay field close is
located also to the northwest with
playing fields located and under
construction you playing fields sorts
sports pictures being constructed in
this location here agriculture
agricultural land lies to the remaining
eastern boundary and also to the south
whilst no public footpaths are run
through the site
the site does contain a series of
permissive footpaths in particular as
one that runs north to south along the
eastern boundary the site is surrounded
long its boundaries by tree and hedgerow
planting with the exception of the
southern boundary which is currently
undefined turning to the layout and
proposals have been revised during the
course of the application in order to
ensure the sensitive eastern boundary of
the site which is here is protected the
layout of the proposal incorporates a
main access route coming off Oak Road
it's just located here and then diverts
in a northern and suddenly direction to
the north the road sorry the Northern
Road loops round two areas of public
open space which is surrounded by
housing forming two green courtyard
areas and sorry which is zoomed in view
of it and here and to the south a
southern spur is formulated in with a
cul-de-sac which also abouts onto a
large area public open space additional
pedestrian access into the site is
proposed of Townsend Road which is this
location here off here and also there is
a path which is also proposed as I said
from a northern to suddely direction
which is accessed off Margaret Court and
goes down the eastern boundary of the
site this will enable and no sorry it
goes further down and it's proposed to
exit onto the agricultural land to the
south via a gated access
a mixer of one two three and
four-bedroom dwellings are proposed
where 35% of the dwellings being
affordable in terms of their design and
form of the dwellings this has been also
revised during the course of the
application following discussions with
offices and also attempts to try and
address the concerns from the Town
Council and ward member it was
considered that the original form in
design was too bland and lacking in
detail and outer character with the area
so for your reference I've put the
original scheme and then what has been
now proposed into the revised designs so
that was the front sorry that's the view
from Oak Road this is going down along
the eastern elevation here so looking
back into the site's so looking in so
the original proposed and then this is
the southern boundary so that's going to
be looking onto the public open space
facing on the southern boundary and this
is just a zoomed in view so we can
appreciate a little bit more of the
detailing of the dwellings this is just
a flavor of the house types that are
being proposed there's two elevations of
two house types here being shown now the
applicants have responded by revising
their house types to include smaller
first-floor window proportions which is
considered to be more in keeping with
the general area also some dwellings now
incorporates the use of bay windows some
false windows and chimneys within the
development in addition Ridge Heights
have also been varied to provide greater
interest within the street scene and use
of Flemish bond brickwork which is
characteristic of Teddington is now been
proposed together with a greater variety
of eaves sill and dental course
detailing also mixing it with arched and
flat headers the houses are proposed to
be constructed from brick
a number of brick types with contrasting
roof tiles there are proposed to this
development also proposes to include
three bungalows which would be backing
on to the Margaret Court Development
turning now to some photographs this is
a view looking down oak road so you can
have a flavor of the approach into the
site this is a view showing the side
gable 39 Oak Road and the Frenchy turn
number 37 it's been 37 here this is a
view sort of following that round now
panning around along the western
boundary with Margaret Court in the
distance as Margaret Court this is
actually taken from Margaret Court
itself looking into the site so this
existing hedgerow is proposed to be
retained the eastern hedgerow retained
and you can see that there has been some
removal this is where sports pitches are
currently into construction that is
proposed to be replanted
the open southern boundary of the site
here and then looking at pretty much
from the approach from oak roads looking
along in a northwesterly direction you
can see the new houses of hay field I
think Jo court case I think being
constructed in the distance in the
northwestern section and Margaret Court
here towards the north and then this is
the final view looking along Oak Road
the sorry property that's number 56 Oak
Road and their existing aside boundary
treatments and side elevation and there
is one update to report which is in the
update sheet and the recommendation
chair is to ground planning permission
well sorry
grant reserved matters I should say
subject to the conditions and notes
details in the report thank you sure
thank you very much so if we go to our
first speaker this evening on this
application for the town council
strengthen our cancer in fragile e who I
believe is objecting I don't have to
tell you how to use all this do I say we
and you do notice three minutes and I'll
give you a half minute warning at the
end there okay can I saw huh thank you
the County Council considered the
original design of the house to be very
poor since it felt there was a limited
architectural detailing such as chimneys
Bay's Korbel leaves segmental arches
over windows expose drafts coining such
windows and variation in red hot rich
heights which resulted in the bland
unimaginative and uninspiring
development the developer then made some
revisions however the Town Council
remained disappointed that the
retrofitting of features on the original
house types is insufficient and does not
create a high quality design worthy of
this site since there's insufficient
variety of external materials still
leaving the design bland in on a minute
initiative the town council is pleased
to see that the affordable housing mix
is more or less in line with structures
neighbourhood plan which you might
realize he's going to referendum at the
end of this month but the can council is
disappointed that the market housing for
the to bed provision suffers in favor of
the for bed provision the Town Council
is most concerned that parking dominates
this development both from the view of
Park in front of plots at the expense of
front gardens and tandem parking for
others which we all know will mean that
the road will be littered with parked
cars giving maneuverability problems to
moving vehicles in another development
South the river
residents tell me this is already a
major issue where they live so we must
get this right from the start rather the
new occupants moving in and having to
live with the same problem a couple of
years ago there was another planning
application flashed south of the river
and one of the counters on this
committee that at that time described it
as one of the purest designs that
efforts have seen being in front of this
committee however that application was
granted and if you visit what resulted
today you would find that that counselor
was right I would therefore ask this
committee not to make the same mistake
and so reject this particular
application and ask the developer to go
back to the drawing board
thank you Joe thank you very much any
any questions councillor bonds
affordable houses it's the market where
the issue is any other questions No
thank you very much and if we go to our
next speaker an objector from the
tilling ttan village residents
Association Emma Scott and you'll have
three minutes and I'll give you a half a
minute warning when you get to two and a
half and when you're ready just press
the button red light should come on only
25% of houses extend directly from oak
road 75% of this site borders properties
on new street Main Street as well as
linking with houses on Townsend Road
houses and all these roads are both
rendered and brick reflecting various
historic
styles and periods the design of the
proposed development is uniform and
lackluster this is not in keeping with
core strategy be6 requiring developers
to meet the highest design standards we
would ask that the houses very in style
and finished including some render
properties and with varying refights and
ridges you will be aware that this
development is of great concern to mesh
residents of the village it increases
the size of the village by nearly 10
percent policy cs9 of the core strategy
states occupiers of neighboring
buildings will be protected from the
impact of development firstly the
planning officer's report acknowledges
that plot 32 contravenes the 45 degree
test we do not believe that failing to
meet minimum requirements as in the
spirit of these policies secondly
residence properties 56 and 39 Oak Road
are unequivocally impacted by this
development and the plots now bring
their properties are the most imposing
of all residents of Margaret Court our
elderly and vulnerable they truly value
their existing outlook over what is
currently open countryside so we ask
that plot 32 is paid compliant that
plots 13 and 14 are reduced in both
height and size and the plots 52 and 53
are made in Spangler's all to protect
the immunity of existing residents
finally the neighbourhood plan
identifies that Teddington has a severe
shortfall of a minty green space the
provision of to play areas is therefore
welcomed however we're aware the
facilities for children aged over 11 are
lacking in the village we would like to
see some rustic play equipment aimed
older children included in the top end
of the larger area of open space and to
maximize the designated open space we
would also ask that the turning space is
significantly shortened and the
remainder of this open space should be
designated as a nature reserve for the
benefit of the local community and
younger residents we also note that at
some stage the natural Hedren eastern
boundary has been damaged and we ask
that it is repaired and retained as part
of this development we welcome the
provision of nesting boxes for birds and
bats but we would like to see numbers
specified and we support other comments
regarding the provision of hedgehog for
an offender fencing until these issues
are addressed we ask that this proposal
is refused so in summary we would ask
that the house is very in style and
finish that plots 32 13 and 14 and plots
7:53 are we considered that a player is
provided for older children half a
minute
but the turning circle is reduced and
designated as a nature reserve and that
the number of bat boxes and bird boxes
is specified and Hedgehog family fencing
is introduced lovely thank you very much
just trying to get all that down other
any questions cancer fielding you refer
to houses are partly rendered how near
are they to this development so some of
the houses on new Street that back onto
this development would be rendered so
the road parallel to the site
just to go over some of those numbers of
the house 13 and 14 whereabouts they
okay I know those two 52 53 okay and
yellow is what three bed and you want
those to be reduced in height made into
bungalows and 52 and 53 52 and 13 and 14
reduced in height 52 and 53 to bungalows
and then did you say 32 and something
else with the 45 degree line okay thank
you any other questions
thank you very much and now we have the
applicant and the architects and
planning consultants of the applicants
so L&Q I think is the applicant in
Millwood hello Malad and odd GSA
architects Christine Goldsmith and
Litchfield planning consultants Rebecca
Cain's who are both here to just answer
questions and we will hear from in Malad
you have six minutes if you wish them
and I will give you a half a minute
warning at five and a half I'm going to
speak for about three or four minutes
and then Christine's going to speak for
the balance of the six minutes that's
yeah we didn't have that down but that's
fine fine by me thank you yeah would it
be possible we've done a CGI of the
development and it's taken looking at
the bottom green so that's an image
of the of the first green okay so yes
explain that as you go great so thank
you chair and members for giving me the
opportunity to speak this evening my
name is Ian Millard and I'm the
Operations Director and I have Rebecca
and Christine here to answer any
technical questions you might have
Ellen Q is a charitable Housing
Association we have around 250,000
people in more than 95,000 homes as we
retain management of our new
developments we have an incentive to
ensure that they are well designed
attractive and finished to our high
quality with no difference in quality
and finish of houses of different
tenures Ellen Q is also too committed to
making a long-term investment in the
local community each year we invest 4
million pounds through the lnq
foundation to support local community
projects we have already supported two
local community groups in tintin
including the scouts L&Q also has an
academy offering a program of
apprenticeships and graduate schemes
that we would apply on this development
we acquired Gallagher estates in August
2017 recruited a local lnq team working
from offices in Leamington Spa and
started reviewing the outlined consent
at the start of the year as this is our
first of a first scheme to be developed
in the area it has been really important
for us to build relationships with
officers the local residents Association
councillor Ralph the town council and
the local community to ensure that we
deliver a high quality residential
development of this site from the outset
of this project we have really engaged
with the TVR a councillor role from the
town council through individual meetings
design workshops which were extremely
productive we have held three
consultation events and have separately
visited residents of marble core all of
these events have informed the design
evolution of the scheme and we would
like to thank members and the public for
attending these sessions we have not
only listened to comments but we have
also responded by making a number of
changes to the scheme including
redesigning the drainage to avoid a
three-month closure of Main Street which
would have affected low
residents and businesses we've
incorporated one bedroom starter houses
rather than flats we have designed a
range of houses they're not all
executive for bed units giving families
the option to stay in the village rather
than move away we've created a balance
between tandem and apron style parking
throughout the development to address
the concerns of the planning offices for
Less apron style parking and the town
councils requirement for Less tandem
parking we've designed an additional 23
unallocated parking spaces to ensure
local streets are not impacted the
original application had none of that
we've provided tracking details of
refuse vehicles to demonstrate that they
can move safely around the site and do
not conflict with the parking proposed
we have updated the planted scheme to
provide native species in areas of open
space and have included bat from bird
boxes and hedge friendly fencing in
response to the ecologist comments of
the and we were providing in an ecology
born habitat management plan and when we
commenced work we've substituted
bungalows for houses beyond margaret's
court to reduce visual impact and
counsel okay troth commended us on this
we've reduced reached heights and
changed roof spaces to reduce impact of
oak Road entrance and provide visual
interest
we gave residents the opportunity select
bricks from the local brick kiln 50
miles from the village and we're using
Flemish bond brick paneling which is
seen on Victorian and Georgian
properties in the village we have
designed in two attractive central
greens which provides safe and
attractive outlook for residents in
include play equipment for small
children required by the section 106 and
an attractive meadow to the South more
suitable for dog walking and a kickabout
area for older children the two access
points on the south boundary have been
retained to enable people to continue to
move through the site freely from north
to south it has been accepted that our
proposed layout is an improvement on the
original outline consent you had four
minutes so far we've got more space the
provision of smaller houses we're
overcoming secured by design matters the
introduction of visitor parking the
provision of more children's place
and a design which is more in keeping
with it into village all of which which
help nurture an improved environmental
and community spirit the application
will deliver much needed new homes for
the district the site will be part of a
consider contractor scheme and we are
working closely with local residents to
minimize any disruption during
construction it is disappointing that
councillor Ralph the Town Council
and the TV are a still object to our
proposals even though we have listened
and made changes to the scheme it should
be noted that there are no objections
for any statutory consultants we are
very proud of and believe in this scheme
and I hope you can support our programs
tonight I now hand over to Christine
Eddington is an attractive village which
has expanded over time reflecting local
materials and the styles and detailing
of those periods we took inspiration
from the handsome well proportioned
predominantly red brick houses in the
surrounding parts of the village the
proposed house design also derived their
character from the local area starting
with an attractive palette of high
quality locally made bricks in a
complementary range of colors and
textures many of the proposed houses
include Flemish bond brickwork which is
such a distinctive detail within
Teddington 30 seconds left we have paid
attention to the proportion of the
buildings and the shape and size of the
windows many of the houses are
white-fronted this means that rooms
benefit from receiving light from two
sides we've made sure there's visual
interest right across the site each of
the 19 different house types from
bungalows to 4 bed family homes is
expressed differently in the variety of
roof forms pitches forms and rich
heights we created a varied roofline
right across the site thank you I'm
afraid that's all we can have thank you
very much
any questions councillor fielding
the bungalows are not wheelchair
bungalows they incorporate features of
lifetime homes which ensures that homes
are designed to be flexible for as wide
a range of different general needs there
were no that was found to be no
requirement for wheelchair housing
within this area therefore we made an
amendment for the application to take
that out
one more councillor fielding rendered
which is a street sort of runs parallel
to this
have you considered doing any rendering
to match the neighboring properties we
would say that the surrounding area is
predominantly brickwork and what we did
to make this theme distinctive and of
Teddington was look at the detailing
colors and textures within brickwork
itself okay thank you II want to put the
map up but just thought of all the
changes that the might be I wondered if
you got any comment about now well well
what we did do we originally on the
original consent there was no
single-story Dillons at all they were
all two-story and above what our
original scheme didn't have any
bungalows in it but as part of the
consultation that we did we did take on
board the conceived the concerns of the
residents yeah at the top of the st.
Margaret's Court and we've changed our
scheme to incorporate bungalows on the
on the boundary so it doesn't affect the
views from the flats of the people that
live in reading some Margaret's court we
just think of those two yellow ones I
think it was are they so so I know that
so
so it has been asked about the two
yellow ones but but the views of some of
Margaret's court are more affected by
the three bungling we have so so we have
addressed the concerns and to be honest
we were commended by counsel role for
the for the action that we have taken
and we went back into Margaret's court
and talk to the residents there and they
were very pleased with what we've done
thank you very much and we do have two
we do have to make a decision on what's
before us of course yes council organ
the town council council freshly made it
comment about one of the plots and I
think he was 32 and a 45 degree line
non-compliant could you comment on that
we've since done a sunlight and daylight
assessment on that property and we
submitted that to the planning officer
to actually demonstrate that there's no
loss of sunlight or daylight or
overshadowing to the new properties that
are proposed okay thank you any more
questions nope thank you very much thank
you very much thank you
could you yes thanks and now we do go to
the ward member cancer Rolfe who has
five minutes good evening
yes okay let's talk about design I want
to explain that developers did have a
meeting with myself three members of T V
RA and the chair of Town Council
planning to discuss the development a
planning application came forward sadly
not taking into account very much of
what was discussed the developers then
presented amendments not discussed with
us which are here before me our original
comments regarding design was of
blandness and uniformity and lack of
variation in rendering and reference the
developers came back with what you see
before you which is all the original
designs with bit stuck on them the odd
porch chimney and slight changes in some
windows we feel these designs are still
unimaginative and dumb whereas the
variation in height and color still
boring red brick come on developers I'm
sure you can build something much more
interesting than what's before you'll
hear the Neighborhood Development Plan
which goes to referendum in three weeks
time states that didn't enhance
shortfall of open space the developer
has addressed this but to the minimum
and I would like to see one of the play
areas in one of the loops to be placed
in the green area at the end of the
turning-point to the right of the
development and to make the equipment
more relevant to older children this
would allow one of the loops to remain
open for the use of residents to have
picnics etc and create a feeling of more
open space I ask that Platz 52 and 53
become larger bungalows and in fact the
residents of Margaret Court also asked
for that this would allow much more open
feeling to the views from the first and
second floor windows of Margaret Court
there is a need for more bungalows for
those older and less able residents in
one of the conditions on page 21 I'm
concerned about the sentence beginning
if within a period of five years my
concern is what happens after five years
if this development is to be adopted by
the Highways Authority then it could
take many more years than five
I think they should read in perpetuity
or at least until adopted we ask that
the curb should be higher than standard
this would be useful to everyone
particularly preventing cars parking
half on pavements and roads we see no
sign of dropped curbs which should be at
a standard requirement allowing
Wes well like those less able to move
around the development there are no dog
bins bins provided again and should be
standard there are no electric charging
points in the garages again this should
be standard now I come to a serious
omission in the list of conditions there
is no mention of construction timings
and construction vehicles Oak Road is a
residential street and a thoroughfare
for children walking to school I would
want to see a ban on construction
vehicles using this road between the
hours of 8:15 and 9:15 a.m. and 2:30 and
3:45 during term time I would want to
see a ban on any construction vehicles
at any time using GNU Street which is a
narrow street with parked vehicles down
both sides I would not want to see any
construction vehicles coming down
Knights Lane from Locksley Road there is
a school care phone football club and
parked vehicles on one side all
construction traffic must approach from
tootington wrote only I would want to
see all construction vehicles parking on
site and not in the residential streets
around and finally I would not expect
building to begin before 8 a.m. in the
morning and no weekend working it's
ironic of the previous owners of this
development Gallagher's very kindly
donated an amount of money to implement
safety issues in all Knights lane
outside the school we're now the only
school in south works year to have 20
miles an hour slowdown signs outside the
school paid for by this development so
let's keep this area completely safe for
our children and young families so to
finish I ask you committee to look at
our adopted core plan and the
neighborhood plan and look to all your
training on how important designers and
agree with myself the Town Council and
the residents of kidding to that design
and street scene could be much improved
it's so important we get this right
please refuse this application on
grounds of poor design and improve on
all conditions as asked for above thank
you
Thank You councillor Kessler Barnes
okay well check that in tech absolute
fielding no it was I'll go for a couple
you mentioned the loop that you would
rather not see there which is that one
nor proposed to have play equipment for
small children I'd like to see one of
those loops completely clear and have
the play equipment put by the turning
point okay well I get leaving the it was
the technical technical term no that's a
an amount of play equipment is that okay
the five-year implementation is for what
is it for trees or standard soft
landscaping condition okay yes if it's
soft landscaping that's what I want to
know yes okay and yes so am I will go
into that it later on the construction
management I think the there was a
condition on the on the outline for
construction management I believe but we
should go into that and technical
questions you don't want anything at the
weekend you don't want anything before 8
a.m. you don't want anything between
8:15 and 9:15 and 2:30 and 3:40 okay now
the nothing using new Street I'm not
that familiar with it is the night lane
bit okay so you can approach nights Lane
from two ways one from the tootington
road and one from the Loxy road if
traffic comes down the Locksley Road it
goes down it will be built on very soon
because
planning for applications coming forward
soon but currently it's fifty miles an
hour
and then it goes down to thirty miles an
hour and then 20 miles an hour because
I've had to slow down signs on the left
is a Football Club and the school and
then there are parked cars you wouldn't
be able to get a large construction
vehicle so you're saying everything has
to come okay thank you very much any
more questions
council fielding quick one the playing
fields that are to the right of the
eastern boundary are they private or are
they of the public use plain feels the
Home Guard Club their sports facilities
the private okay no more questions thank
you very much counselor very good and
now we go to technical questions to the
officers counselor bounce management no
management remember that we had a
management and bid for school which
worked very well do you think it's
important that everybody knows what it
is and his idea to is the one or is
there not one but to approve this
application we would want to see one
rest assured there is one it's attached
on the original outline permission so
there is a restriction requiring
condition 12 of the outline permission
requires a construction method and
phasing statement to include
construction traffic management plan to
be implemented and one of the clauses of
the details that the statement has to
include is including delivery of all
materials to the site including details
of how deliveries will not take place
during peak time hours of the highway
network in the vicinity of the
application site and details of the
nature and number of vehicles temporary
warning signs to be
used and measures to manage crossings
across the public highway so that's
already firm down in the construction
phase yes during the construction phrase
yes we will have control we ensure that
any car parking in association with this
development is on site ok so I just want
to get over that again everything
cannister Ralph talked about can we can
we add I know because it was agreed in
outline but presumably we can we can
detail it at this stage well the the
issue is about timings and ensuring that
peak flows of traffic aren't paragraph
two of the construction management plan
will include that includes ok so we've
got the time what we want we certainly
want it to include the school times
obviously I mean 8:00 a.m. sounds very
early to me to start constructing but it
will have things like that in it would
it I mean does it have the times it
doesn't specify the times in this okay
and can we go for no weekend working the
process that would be followed is the
condition sits on the outline permission
and that condition requires the
submission of that vamp writer of the
commencement of developments and at the
point of submission officers could take
what councilor Ralph and others have
said into account along with the
statutory consultation to the highway
authority to take into account knows
those hours that have been requested an
alternative to that is to put a note on
any reserved matters permission
clarifying to the applicant exactly the
sort of hours that with the
to just part of that submission I think
well I think that would be good because
we've had this thing about the weekend
we've had the ATM we've had the school
times we've had the directions of
traffic and the the roads that shouldn't
be used and I'd like that ought to be
included and some had to be to better
check you know can you check that with
me as a chair or the ward member or
something or the chair which were 8:15
to 9:15 in the morning and 2:30 to 3:45
in the afternoon 2:30 to 3:45
we've got no work before 8:00 a.m. which
seems very reasonable seems a bit early
no weekend construction which seems
reasonable okay late to presume we're
not putting later on probably not okay
it's normal and then the the approach
tonight slain from Teddington Road as
opposed to the other road instead of not
from not zero but from so now it's
laying in the direction of nothing from
the Loxley Road nothing on you Street at
all
and I think that was it actually great
okay and we have some more questions
counselor organ Thank You chairman the
first question is about plot 32 and the
light situation would you like to
explain it certainly if I can refer you
back to the committee reports I have
addressed the issue
sorry
page 18 if we go to residential immunity
I have referred to it arts are actually
page 19 paragraph want a third paragraph
down where I've acknowledged about the
fact that contravenes a forty
five-degree test however the applicants
have provided a daylight and sunlight
analysis or the BRE standards which
still demonstrate that the levels of
daylight and sunlight were within that
property and bearing in mind that it's
going to have a two meter high boundary
defense alongside it
it's basically wouldn't have any
unacceptable levels of wouldn't have a
reduction to such an unacceptable level
councillor Atkinson thanks Janet there
the lack of electric charging points has
been mentioned as well as an increase in
I think in the height of curbs could you
comment on that it's the latter control
the applicant has identified that they
will be providing electric charging
points within the garages within the
development itself but I do note that we
haven't got a specific condition
specifying that so members because in
include that within the application in
terms of curb Heights that would be a
matter for the highway authority to
consider it would be because if you
referred to the condition the
construction of the foot ways etc it
would be - in terms of the standard
specification of the Highway Authority
that was not very request
okay um okay yes I mean on both both of
those things if it was going to go -
agreed
electric charging point reserved for
each house would that be yeah I mean we
normally we normally include nowadays we
normally include electric charging
points on all new development so I'm
surprised yeah we haven't got one not in
every house thank you
the the issue is that you have got apron
car parking and it's how to facilitate
that with a charging point because what
we were what the what would the
condition would require is that we have
cabling - - we normally put it into the
garages of the plots it doesn't have to
be in a garage it isn't it can be in the
front of the house
this might be something we've come come
back to I'm not sure it's something I
think we'd all like to see is as many
charging points on as many houses as
possible I can I've seen plenty of
charging points outside we've got one in
our car park for instance okay so we're
going to look it into that Louise is
looking into that counts of fielding I
think is the company that is doing the
development is going to put up a
management company to run the site I
gather they will then no doubts issue
service charges which could if the trees
and the plants don't last the five years
would then be a hefty sum on the
occupiers those properties can we make
sure that the the trees are maintained
for a longer period than five years to
try and get around that problem okay
yeah that that's an issue that came up
earlier as well wasn't it in terms of
the standard landscaping condition for
soft landscaping as a five year
replacement and the reason for that is
obviously young trees are at the most
vulnerable in the first five years
that's why it's that figure that's the
standard condition it's never been
extended from that and that's the one
the Planning Inspectorate would use I
think you'd need to have some specific
reason why this site have to have that
level of protection in order to extend
it in order to make the condition a
reasonable one and therefore comply with
the tests okay I'm going to jump in
there I know there are people waiting on
that can we at least have it five years
from the completion of the last house
that seems to make sense as you've got
construction traffic and you know things
that can go wrong could take five years
to build that because it stands it's
within five years of the planting of
whatever tree
whatever it may be that that is actually
less if it's on the last house because
some planting would if you follow
because that development size will be
done in phases so some of the earlier
planting would go in but if kicks in
five years from the last house it could
be less it could be maybe that in that
case I'm not saying it would be
unreasonable to have more than five
years I'm just saying it would be
non-standard but if members feel that
the landscaping on this for whatever
reason
was a particular importance perhaps
given that the number of parks and that
kind of thing involved there may be a
site-specific justification that
justifies more than five years
okay one more I just wanted to know who
would monitor when the trees are going
to be dealt with in terms of independent
monitoring that would be done to us that
be down to our enforcement team I've got
several people here are going to know
cancer brain they do have been
collection points within their proposals
and also there's been it's not what
you're getting at is and also for the
isn't accounted for cast a bounce about
the trees I don't know who's taking over
this green area and to make sure that
the people that are taking it over with
the facilities and residents or the
council or whatever that they are the
people to continue to say that the trees
are sufficiently yeah growing
appropriately and if we go to doc dog
bins and drop curbs are the drop curbs
it seems sense of where there should be
drop curbs or nowadays
for wheelchair users or you know when
you've got when you've got people
walking from there from one place to
another while using a wheelchair from
one place to another all a pushchair
from one place to another that when they
go over a road they don't have to go
down a curb they go down a dropped curb
I think whether the highway
specifications would require as such
that you'd have crossing points when you
have got any sort of Junction area
that's me on my own personal estate
where you have got a crossing point kind
of makes it well that can be covered and
the potentially could be covered into
the hard landscaping ok and can we go
back to where were we electric charging
points electric charging points I've
just had a look at our draft SVT which
it just specified for residential
developments a minimum of 7k kilowatt
electricity cabling to the charging
points it's provided and it does say per
dwelling with a garage or driveway so we
could include that in there
excellent cancer fielding one to two
points one is the request for rendering
of some of the houses can we ask for
that to be looked into and the second
one is I think we ought to look at
disabled facilities within some of the
bungalows for disabled people sorry turn
it turn to the last point the
requirement for a building regs lifetime
home standards that's now dealt with
peripartum with building regs in terms
of having facilities in all their homes
to be up to lifetime home standards that
is quite an onerous requirements so for
lifetime home standards you're including
hoists within the bungalow that's wide
enough to always and things like that
within within the development there is a
forgot the exact percentage but in
response to
the neighborhood plan policy there is a
requirement for I think a substitute
about 25% of the dwellings to be
lifetime home standards while seized
about the proposals don't meet all of
the criteria because they haven't got
hoist facilities in them they are pretty
much up to spec for a significant
proportion of these so I think they have
gone as far as we can push them at this
particular moment in time bearing in
mind we haven't got an adopted
neighborhood plan although if there is
substantial weight to be attributed to
it at the present moment in time okay
thank you
in terms of rendering the applicant has
assessed whether or not they would like
to have that within the development
there then their way forward has been to
have a variety of brick types and also
brick detailing but if members would be
think that is is a weight that we could
potentially do subject to the receipt of
an amended amended plans showing the
introduction of rendered properties
within the development I think that's
what we have to go with okay thank you
very much good good questions any more
no then we should go to debate on this
Clara bands a big site okay concerned
about the management plan because of the
school and the parking in that
particular Road with only one entrance
as far as I'm concerned we're moving
forward the applicant is listening to
our concerns about wheelchair access and
various other things and I'm only too
happy to propose it Thank You councillor
boss anyone council fielding
I am concerned about the the block of
red brick I believe what the new Street
is it new Street the one that runs down
they have rendering I think it would
break up the and go a long way I hope to
meet the requirements of the ward member
and the local council apart from that I
can't see a great deal of alterations
that I am worried about the long term on
the trees and the plants but if we can't
do much more about that under that leave
then I'm quite happy to go along with
councillor Barnes on him okay that's
another council organ thank you
the construction traffic issue can be a
very real issue when you have a site
like this that just has one access road
which is where traffic does residential
traffic does have to park in that road
and you have access into oak road from
Knights Lane and again you have the
situation it doesn't matter which way
you come you still have traffic parked
in that road and you have a lot of
pedestrian activity going on and I
remember a previous development where
the relationship between the
constructors and the residents was
verging on to one of non respect and I
would like to think that in some way
there can be some undertaking by the
developers that the residents concerns
and fears for their safety and their
amenities are protected within any
arrangements that are put together about
the traffic management Thank You
councillor consume thanks chairman
certainly there's been enormous amount
of dialogue between two principal Town
Council and the county councillor but
what does impact upon me actually
looking at these plan of the back the
number of houses around which must
obviously mean a lot of residents
yet we've only had eight letters of
objection that I can only assume means
the residents will be aware of what is
occurring and they're quite happy so
okay thank you I'm ready to second the
proposal of Chancellor Bantz
if I don't know what we need to include
in this but we've talked a lot about
various items we've talked about the
construction management plan so I would
like that to be checked with the chair
when that comes through and the ward
member I'd like them yes absolutely
I'd like the the the issue of higher
curb Heights noted to the to the County
Council you know and for though you know
the reason we want higher curb cards if
it's possible if it's agreed by the
county council is to prevent that
parking which we see is a problem so it
should be a benefit to future residents
definitely the electric charging points
which aren't in the dog bins in the hard
landscaping a reminder of the drop curbs
for again standard highway crossing of
roads and things a reminder of filling
in that eastern boundary soft
landscaping and there was mentioned from
the developer of Hedgehog friendly
boundary treatments and fencing to
ensure that's still in there and on the
soft landscaping if you know if you made
as hot as as compelling as possible
you've got the five years in there if
you can do it an either/or whichever
comes later whichever is the most
strong just to be clear all night open
to committed to it to extend that time
what I said was it wouldn't be
reasonable to do it you just need a
site-specific justification I'd I don't
I don't think we need to extend that it
is important in this in this you know
we've it's open countryside so the the
the landscape is incredibly important
and I think there's been noted in the
report so if we if you want to put it
for six seven years seven years great
lovely
could we do look at rendering of some of
the houses to be agreed with yourself
and the ward member well I I don't want
him rendered so I wouldn't go along with
that I'm happy they got a design ethic
here they've thought it through so I'm I
wouldn't want them changing that
necessarily great so we have a proposal
we have a seconder with the comments and
notes and amendments mentioned check and
I'll just go through what's going to be
subject to is what's going to be
conditions and what's going to be notice
just so everyone's clear on if you can
figure it out that's great yes okay
the first change would be to condition
three is recommended that would go from
five years to seven years on the
landscape placement planting there would
be an additional condition seven for
electric vehicle charging points there
would be a fifth note regarding how the
construction management plan under the
outline is dealt with and what we've got
the notes on that down as you
highlighted earlier when that comes in
the that would need to be run past you
as chairman and the board member
beyond that the only other one I had was
the dog bins I'm not really sure how we
could encapsulate that in whatever can
to determine because it could be under
the hard landscaping scheme so what he
could do actually is a hard landscaping
scheme including elevational drawings
etc to include provision of dog bins so
note saying when the soft landscaping
comes in it shall include gapping of
that seventh note saying when the hard
landscaping comes in under condition for
it shall be Hedgehog friendly and we've
got so we've got we have got the
comments the requests to count accounts
we can't dictate to them that the curb
heights are raised to prevent parking
for the sake of the amenity of future
residents yeah I think probably the most
we could encapsulate in to that is that
the officers will undertake to explore
with the Highway Authority okay so we'll
go to the vote with all that understood
all those in favor of granting planning
permission thank you very much so this
committee has resolved to grant planning
permission for application 1801 nine six
four pm land off Oak Road tootington I'm
afraid no answer well
well yeah well we've we've made our
decision now
so we are now going to move on to the
next application now if we're already I
think 1801 five to two mana farm duck
Lane and we have Charlotte fish thank
you Thank You chairman the site is
indicated on the map by the black circle
the application site is located in
Welford on Aben on duck lane actually
you want to hang on well wait a minute
if people are leaving that's good and or
chatting outside please because we're
going under the next item
okay Thank You Charlotte thank you Joe
the site is indicated on the map by the
black circle the application site is
located in buffered on Aven on deck lane
it is located on the eastern edge of the
village and within the conservation area
this slide shows the application site
edged in red you can see the two
separate areas of the red line as well
as the visibilities blazed on to duck
Lane the application site includes a
barn on the northern site of the side of
the site which is great he listed and
shaded in red manna farmhouse is also
great - listed and sited at right angles
to the listed barn fronting on to duck
Lane the red line also includes a
section to the south of manna farmhouse
where a new access driveway and turning
head would be positioned for the east of
manna farm
the pink line of the conservation area
can also be seen on the slide along with
two trees on the eastern side of the
site opposite the highway which benefit
from tree preservation orders a
right-of-way also runs to the east
dotted but indicated by the dotted line
a detached residential property known as
eight quid abuts the site to the south
with walnut tree cottage located to the
north open fields about the site to the
west this is an application for full
planning permission for the change of
yeast conversion and alteration of the
existing grade 2 listed barn into teeny
dwellings
along with the change of use of parcels
of land into residential in addition a
new access driveway and turning head
would be sited to the southern part of
the site following removal of the trees
and soft landscaping in this area this
slide shows a zoomed in section of the
site plan showing only the proposed
access and driveway the listed summer
house which would be sited approximately
naught point to 5 metres from the
driveway is also indicated the access
now is to three point four meters in
width where at Bert's duck Lane due to
the presence of the historic wall
immediately to the north the width of
the driveway would be approximately five
meters and it would be approximately
forty four meters in length
projecting into the agricultural land
the West this slide shows that proposed
north and south elevations of the barn
the conversion would involve additional
reef lights and openings this photo
shows the frontage of the site when
viewed from duck claim the red arrow
indicates the approximate position of
the access point you can see the listed
wall and manna farmhouse to the
right-hand side of the proposed access
point this photo has taken from slightly
further north along duck lane looking
back to the proposed access coin point
again it's indicated by the red arrow
this photo is taken from the front of
mana farmhouse you can see the farmhouse
itself on the left-hand side
with a listed barn centrally you can
also see the gated existing access this
photo shows the existing southern
elevation of the listed barn
showing the existing openings and
materials the existing rival hard
standing is visible to the right hand
side of the photo as well as the access
point this photo shows the rear
elevation of man a farmhouse with the
existing hard Stanley again visible in
the foreground the garden area is
contained by the wall to the right-hand
side of the photo this photo shows again
the existing hard standing facing
towards the west towards the
agricultural land beyond the curtilage
listed wall is on the left-hand side of
the photo this way too has taken from
the south of the barn facing again to
the south towards the agricultural land
towards where the turning head would be
located the curtilage list of all is
seen on the left-hand side again this
photo is taken moving further towards
the south where the turning head would
be positioned the hedge to the left-hand
side on the photo marks the residential
curtilage this photo is of their
curtilage listed summer house close to
the southern boundary and the access to
I would run to the rear of this building
and in front of the fence which can be
seen the residential property known as I
quit is visible in the background this
photo shows the side of the summer house
on the right hand side and the existing
shed the access driver would be
positioned in this location this photo
has taken adjacent to the hedge line
facing into the agricultural land to the
west this is where the turning head
would be sited this aerial photo shows
the listed farmhouse and the listed barn
this array shows the approximate
location of the proposed access and
turning herd and this red circle
indicates the position of the curtilage
listed summerhouse just to clarify there
are some updates neigh located locates
within the update sheet officer
recommendation is to refuse the
application for planning permission for
the reason and Nate which can be found
on page 45 of the agenda Thank You
chairman thank you very much
so we go to our speakers now supporting
this application from the parish council
is councillor David Broadbent and David
Koepp qui-gon Ron I'm on the wrong page
Jamie Hockaday sorry about that I'm
right at the end too eager so three
minutes to two and a half minute warning
just before us to help could I ask the
applicant our sins and photographs in
showing the access which is the primary
point of being here and they haven't
been shown yet so I'm looking for a
photograph that we lovely thank you
good evening counselors the parish
council support this application that
the conversion of the barn and manna
farm we are pleased to see that the
listed building consent has now been
granted this application has been going
on for nearly a year with a good working
relationship between the applicant
parish council the listed building
officer and the conservation officer in
respect of the conversion of the barn
the applicants has done everything that
the authors of officers requested
produced the number of units from 3 to 2
made numerous changes to the Interior
removed the car barn altered the park
our parking arrangements reduced the
numbers of number of windows and as
mentioned above all of the outstanding
matters relating to the barn and their
conversion have been resolved to the
extent that the LBC is now agreeing to
proved however there is one issue
remaining and that is the proposed
access from Manor Farm itself that's why
we're here tonight we have a situation
where the listed built building percent
is now agreed yet we're recommending
refusal because at this point of access
this is not a new access and that
photograph shows it and there are other
records are shared as well the proposal
is to open up that existing access and
the applicant has gone a long way to
reduce as you heard earlier the original
opening point now to a point of three
point four meters socially it doesn't
affect that wall on the left-hand side
of the slide trees are also going to be
removed they are lay lawn day non-native
and no particular amenity value the
immediate neighbors are supporting
removal of those trees they're also
supporting this application the opening
up of the existing access is also an
advantage in terms of the construction
traffic for the barns otherwise
construction construction construction
traffic would be using the current
single access which you've already seen
and that would affect potentially
mr. structures the bombs and and the
house so in conclusion the applicants
have done everything they can to meet
the needs of all officers and the only
point you're being asked to consider is
is the access the Parish Council have
been offered a meeting between all
parties to see if this matter can be
resolved but unfortunately that was
declined by Stratford District Council
so we asked that you support this
application and allow this existing
access to be used thank you thank you
very much the question it's kind of sir
fielding construction traffic away from
the single entrance as far as the plans
have shown there is no way that the two
if this application or if this access is
opened up it provides the ability to use
two accesses one for the house and one
for the bonds and therefore construction
constructive traffic could use either
this this opening is about 80 yards away
from the listed building whereas the
other access that already exists is
adjacent to both properties okay I see
what Costa fielding means there though I
mean on the plans that we've got to look
at this Drive just goes up to the little
summer house at the corner of the thing
and then there's a long space of field
to get to the barn so it doesn't look
like you would send construction traffic
up this new Drive to get to the barn any
comments and I think you could you could
use either
council organ Thank You chairman um when
was this accessed last in youth well I
don't actually know that I would prefer
that to the next speaker the owners of
the property okay thank you any other
questions No thank you very much and
we'll go on into the web page there are
no objectives so the applicant and
supporters we have all of a spicer I've
got you down as agent and mrs. Sally
Stratton lovely
I've got Nicola Bromley here as well I
know you're happy there okay thank you
so you have three minutes between you
and I'll tell you at two and a half good
evening councillors my sister and I
would like to thank Charlotte for an
agreement to the LBC planning conditions
we understand that the only remaining
issue is the new access and parking area
for the farmhouse although this is
referred to as new access it's simply
the reinstatement of a historic access
to the estate from the 1920s manna farm
was brought by our great-grandparents in
1934 by which time it had ceased to be a
working farm my children are the fourth
generation to live there we've tried to
work closely with the officers
throughout the process and at the
request of both Charlotte and Dale
Barker have reduced the entrance to 3.1
meters meaning that none of the listed
wall needed to be removed as the gaps
already there the only reason that why
netting is there to keep my dog in part
of the proposal is the removal of three
conifers are joining our neighbors who
are supporting the application mr. and
mrs. Turner find the trees very
overbearing and they prevent anything
growing in their garden around them the
existing garden board is situated 10
metres from the boundary fence so the
proposed driveway would not even reach
the lawn
both existing and newly planted trees
would totally screen the driveway from
the house in the garden we've moved the
parking area away from the garden as
this was a concern for the conservation
officer this is now at the end of the
driveway the conservation officer has
commented that this does now preserve
the immediate setting of the farmhouse
although still suggests
an element of harm to the undeveloped
land this land however is divided from
the main open land by a row of trees but
approximately 10 metres high we own the
surrounding acreage which is mown grass
mature hedging and established trees the
access is some distance away from the
farmhouse itself as this is the only
place and independent entrance could be
provided due to the boundary wall around
the farmhouse one of the case officers
comments is the access is not required
to make the barn conversion work with
all due respect this is not strictly
true if the existing driveway is used
for all three dwellings this would mean
in planning terms at least eight cars
sharing this area area consequently the
barns would have very little privacy
with vehicles for all three homes
passing at close proximity especially
two dwelling two surely a house such as
manna farm deserves its own entrance and
this also prevents the current driveway
looking like an overcrowded carpark with
no privacy to the barns this is not a
financial project for us if we were
developers we would just take the access
off the application but we're not this
is our forever ago this is going to be
our forever home and as such we believe
separate axis for the farmhouse is a
fundamental part of the scheme we
sincerely hope that you are able to
grant this application to my sister and
I enabling us all to stay at a fast 30
seconds which is so very dear to us
thank you very much great thank you very
much
any questions substantial are you going
to be dividing it up so or having some
sort of fence to prevent people from the
bonds going across toward back of your
house car parking and converted the new
driveway will provide parking and as to
the plan provided the officers as a
construction method so I plan which
indicates how the two areas are linked
temporarily junior construction works
across from the
the area decided to the carpark nearest
the barns with temporary roadway answers
a previous question as well
any other questions cancer organ thank
you but just to repeat my question when
was the last time that the access to the
South was used it was in the nineteen
twenties the on the Ordnance Survey map
that's up there and it was it was
probably used around the 60s they used
to be a tennis court the lawn was tennis
court in the sixties so it was just
gradually not okay no other questions
thank you very much okay and the ward
member cassa Barnes who has five minutes
thank you this bomb did come to a
meeting about a year ago three dwellings
and a lot of work has gone on between
the planning officer and the applicant -
if you like getting right our officers
were not happy about a lot of things CPR
we weren't happy about a lot of things
and over this year we addressed all
they've all been addressed and a lot of
work has gone into getting this
beautiful barn with three different
types of stone in the floor wattle and
daub in the middle it really needs
saving and we thought we'd sort of you
know nearly got there then all of a
sudden they decide that they didn't like
the drive the CBRE
didn't have any comments originally and
still haven't got any comments about the
drive it is a long drive
my sheep didn't get out to their fault
that's why they're wise up there and
their dog but so as far as I'm concerned
it's a beautiful old building which
could be saved
I feel that the reduction in the size of
the roadway or drive as you like to call
it is better and the other thing which
was said by the applicant was there are
two Lyle and E trees there now you will
say that the properties are planted
trees everywhere they were a bit of a
nuisance really when I'd be shaved they
or put some motion there and I'll fetch
them in that's all I need these two
Leyland e trees have got the support of
the people next door because they have
nothing growing in their garden
whatsoever and this year in Welford has
had five or six trees which ever look
for water under gallons a day and the
number of building
and they're cracking of two of those
elicited so what do you feel that these
trees would be advantageous to the
neighbor to come out and I don't see or
feel that this drive will be an
intrusion me in the open countryside has
put forth by the conservation architect
and I think that it's a wonderful a lot
of work been gone and I hope that you
fully support it god happy to answer any
questions on on the area the highways
are not opposing this with the amount of
shopping coming out through that little
gateway which as you conceive in the
picture it was very narrow and you
couldn't get a bail is over there hardly
so I'm concerned I'm sorry that this has
to come to committee but I feel that you
should approve the application it will
be a great benefit to the village thank
you very much cancer cancer fielded at
your venerable age do you recall that
track ever been used or part of it being
used yeah well I do know that the
postman that still lives in the village
Beauty up to the war he told me but I
lived in 1958 though before the news
then except there was a gap there then
we have to put the great any other
questions counts raccoons come to the
bond you mentioned something about the
little entrance and by having the
proposal adopted it would help traffic
safety is my interpretation correct of
what I think who said and if so would
you just give a bit of elaboration on it
please well what I'm saying is if all
the traffic were to try and come to that
little gating patch between two listed
buildings and the road is no more than
three meters wide
it is a private road having the other
access will make
entrance substantially better and safer
than it is at the moment with with the
barn being used okay any other questions
no thank you very much counselor so
technical questions thanks Lara the
priorities Manor contacted the
applicants did intend to address both
concerns
hidden relation just to the driveway and
access or yes there has been a series of
amended plan throughout the life of the
application in terms of the barn
conversion however we did request Amanda
plans removing the access driveway from
the scheme which the applicants have not
put forward for consideration for the
reasons they were dressed
any other questions council urban thank
you if I can ask the existing access is
there any planning reason why all three
properties shouldn't be able to use that
and what is the visibility for any
traffic coming out of the proposed new
access in terms of the existing access
the County highways authority have no
objections to the use of the access for
either two or three dwellings and
sufficient parking for the number of
dwellings
so three dwellings could be cited within
the existing hard standing the
visibility's plays for the proposed
access have been shown on this redline
plan and are acceptable to the highway
authority due to the low speed of the
road caster fielding
probably more of debate but it seems to
me that opening up what was a track
going up between the the houses there's
got to be a question on this yeah why is
it if that is the case that it is all
your dick all they're doing is using an
existing road where are you concerned
about the parking up further up there
proposed access we do believe was
historically used as an agricultural
access in similar sighting to what has
been proposed between the dates which
were about 1920 up to just before the
1960s but this access was only for
agricultural purposes and would not have
been as formalized as proposed for this
application we would consider that there
would be an intensification of the
existing access due to the addition of
two new dwellings on the site
however the Highways Authority have no
objection to that intensification of the
youth okay any other questions if we
were mindful to grant permission for
this one could we the highways to
approve an amended plan for the access
that's now being described
could you could you clarify why you
would want that to happen I'm not sure
if they have objected or not to the
access that you have another plan for
they've not objected to the proposals as
it stands
so if members were to grant permission
they can be happy that the County
Council Highway Authority also
I believe that we should grant this the
track itself is all have been used in
historical reasons yes I can't see why
we they don't divide up the the bigger
area but I can understand the privacy
aspect of it but in my view there is no
complaint from highways the only there's
nothing from the parish or the ward
member and I don't see why we shouldn't
grant it I'm just going to go into
debate and sort of before one of the
office is sitting in the audience jumps
down my throat unless maybe I can ask
the officer to say how we should look at
impacts on heritage the reason this is
up for refusal is because its impact on
heritage the impact of this drive I only
on the listed building the setting of
the listed building somewhere which page
I don't know it tells us how what weight
we are to give to that page 36 about
halfway down the section entitled
impacts on listed buildings and that
sits out what the case law is on what
parts of the Act are relevant I see it
I've got it and I thank you very much so
special weight or considerable
importance and weight to the
desirability of preserving the setting
of listed buildings that is why it has
been refused having said that I agree
with you that we should go against
officers in this case and grant
permission I think that wait you know I
acknowledge there is some harm to the
setting of the listed building I think
it's very slight harm I think because
it's a existing or an old access being
brought back into use although it's not
a domestic access that's that's some way
ameliorates it I think the fact that
there will be less parking
in in the existing courtyard also is a
benefit and those two things our way I
think the very slight harm to the to the
to the listed building curtilage that I
have given way to trip so back to
councillor fielding and considering that
they discussed this with the neighbors
they're taking down trees to make it
more amenable I think that it's okay did
you make a proposal by the way you did
okay cash for Atkinson no no okay thank
you kanzaki-san council organ if that
were to be granted where is the
pedestrian access from the proposed
parking area to the farm house
so the pedestrian access would either be
back along the driver and then along
duck lane or possibly along the fields
and then around into the existing hard
standing that way any comments casual or
go to the bait but to the vote
yeah thank you character kissing okay if
chair we can just clarify and agree the
reasons for the ground mmm you're saying
members that you acknowledge slight harm
to the listed building but that this
harm is outweighed by the benefits of
reducing the parking in the existing
courtyard
yeah kind of
yes I think and and the fact that it's
an existing historic access that's being
used any conditions possible conditions
probably best if we get if you agree
delegated authority of the officers to
do the final if you can do that through
the chip with the chair as well yes yeah
okay do members want to know what the
conditions are are they happy through
the chair and
I'm sure materials is in there so so we
will agree that okay so we shall go to
the vote all those in favor of granting
planning permission thank you very much
so
this committee has resolved to grant
planning application 1801 5 to 2 now for
the next two items I'm going to be
standing down so I need a proposal which
council brain do we have a seconder he's
the older start or any other any other
proposals no okay thank you
and we're going to have a five-minute
break
good evening with just waiting pecans
love feeling
I'm now waiting for a senior officer oh
I'll try again
oh good evening everybody I'm chairman
for the next two items I'm very sorry
that I haven't got a tie but I wasn't
expecting to be chairman so I can't be
hung drawn and quartered we move on to
the first application 1602 2/3 3/4 can I
have an officer's report like HM this is
a full clarification for the eruption of
5 dwellings and associated works with
the demolition of existing double garage
as you can see on the slide the
application site is within the main draw
sense of steadily as indicated as
indicated by the black dots on your plan
this is an aerial satellite view of the
proposed development sites signified by
the red arrow one can see the first
development is to the rear of Lord's
Lane little wood green and is a short
distance away from Bromsgrove Road the a
4 4 8 here we have a submitted site
location plan which is listed which
shows application in more detail on this
post site layout plan one can see the
proposed footing of the five dwellings
in addition to car and cycle parking one
can also see the proposed vehicle
turning area in addition to the proposed
bin saw area for the dwellings and the
use of the existing access which is just
actors here of Lords Lane here here we
see the proposed the other proposed
elevations of the dwellings they are
proposed to be to storage
gable properties with pitch Drew's
they comprised four semi-detached
and one detached property there are two
three beds and three to bed properties
within that one can see the proposed
Ridge Heights here of the front
elevation for the detached property it's
partially set down from the other
properties by approximately 1.1 meters
and makes a slight to change to the
intrusive more than a variety into the
vernacular the proposed materials are to
be facing brickwork before the detached
property you to the far left and also to
the two semi detached properties here
the middle to 75% semi-attached
properties are to be proposed to be
render and all of them are to have
concrete tile roofing now we have some
photos of the site and its surroundings
here we are standing on the southeastern
end of Lord's Lane looking Northwest
words one can see the proposed point of
access here and one course see we're in
a what is a residential cul-de-sac here
we have we are stood at the post point
of access looking south westwards it's
also here everyone can see number three
a promise grove road as we are looking
at it here we are stood facing the
western part of the sites to the rear of
the properties along a little wood green
one can also see also see the fairly
overgrown nature of the sites in its
current form here we've stood at the
northern end of the site looking
southwards when we see the proposed
garage elements here this brown building
that is proposed to be demolished as
part of this proposal listen to one can
see here an existing electrical
substation which is outside of the red
line of the boundary of the site on the
eastern boundary here we're stood in the
middle of the application site looking
south east woods we can see here the
rear elevations of the properties along
Lord's Lane chair that is my
presentation there are no details on the
update sheets
chairman my recommendation is to grunt
approval for this planning application
for the reason it sets out page
of your gender pack thank you thank you
we have one representative from studly
Parish Council for Beaman is there any
photos that the officers have put up or
yourself that you would like when you
speak Thank You chair I did actually
submit a couple of photos there we are
which which I would just not refer to if
we can through the presentation Thank
You Jen as you're aware yes as you were
certainly is very fortunate we are
surrounded by beautiful green fields
open countryside and Greenbelt
which means if we have any development
in the village we have to make the most
of it
development within the village has to be
high quality has to meet the needs of
the residents and has to be in a design
that makes it attractive and welcomes
people in the parish council feel that
the design of these buildings do not I
think the biggest problem we'll have
through this site though is access as
you can see and the house on the left
hand side actually belongs to my uncle
and my brother used to live on the right
hand side believe it or not there is an
access gate that goes onto this roadway
well what was the access to the garages
on the property on the left highways
have suggested yellow lines to get round
the exit and exit here to protect the
park in how you do that on somebody's
property I fail to see it is a real
difficult to site to get into if you can
show the other one this is I think I'll
show one looking down the road as well
this is typical parking down the road
when the officer took the photo that was
must've been a very rare day because
normally there is parking all the way
down and very often on the other side of
the road as well so it is very
restricted this is where the problem
comes in not that long ago in this very
council chamber set with quite a few
other cancers in here we are training
session on planning applications and
putting conditions on conditions put on
application must be reasonable
appropriate and in
possible we do not believe that put in a
condition on that means residents have
to use a private waste collector to
enable them to have waste collected from
their building is enforceable we don't
think it's reasonable and we don't think
it's appropriate we believe that better
work could be done there is alternative
access routes into this site if for the
developer to work with other other
property owners around and actually get
a site entrance that works we do not
believe the set current proposal will
work we think it will cause all sorts of
issues with neighbors around emergency
vehicles certainly the refuse collection
will not work and asking residents to
actually have a private contractor who's
going to sort out who prays what cancel
tax what the differences between
everybody else just so that you get a
private contractor to collect waste I
find that very thing and I think that in
itself is justification for refusal the
design is poor the access is not
possible and the conditions given for
making this a pro are not appropriate
for this particular location so we would
urge that it is refused for those
specific reasons there any questions can
we ask the for the plan to come back up
showing the
you refer to another entrance yes if I
could as you see between number four you
got number four and six and then you've
got to a and nineteen on the bottom
right hand corner that is a gouge block
there that is below to a and also there
is a double garage on four to six if
agreement could be reached with those
property owners a road could go in there
which would make that far safer make
that far more appropriate for the the
access in an air to there and
alternative parking arrangements could
have been made on-site for those
specific residents that would lose that
parking so it would just be there to get
an agreement with those residents and
then a safe means of access could be got
into that side they would actually
enable a proper delivery wagon to get
internet I was going to ask highway seem
to be nothing getting because I've had a
contribution can you elaborate on that
all yes this is this waste collection
scheme because the site is not big
enough to get a waste collection wagon
in and out the idea was to put the bins
at the entrance the clothes that doesn't
work because then it means residents
can't get in and it is then very
difficult actually for the wagon to
reverse to get to there so the proposal
is that a private waste collection
company with a smaller vehicle will make
arrangements with the residents and
management company to go and collect the
residents waste instead of the district
council collecting and obviously then
paying a fee to the management company
for setting that up okay has explained
to me you know any other questions
okay thank you for bringing that to our
attention okay have you got another
question just a quick one which I may
not be allowed is all those garages
you're referring to between four and
whatever it is to a or they derelict or
they continue they are they are well the
work urges in where this plot was that
are all owned by the lease holder for
the particular site so they are a
leasehold but they are used by the rest
until number four number six and number
two I at present okay thank you very
much thanks Jay you have the ward member
next because unfortunately we don't
appear to have the applicant hazel
I'm the adjoining ward member and really
I want to raise an objection into this
application and I might reiterate some
of the things Paul said but of the LMP
Pierre paragraph 130 states the
permission should be refused for the
development of poor design that fails to
take the opportunity for improving the
character and the quality of an area
you've seen for yourself that doesn't do
it does it 531 of the LPS States apart
from promoting sustainability we did
help to raise the standard of design
more generally in the area that's
certainly not happening it does not say
it should accept mediocre or poor
quality just to get a project finished
and the highway matters Paul actually
raised the issue is not around the
strategic road network but it's about
the narrow roads and the entrances but a
Down Lord's Lane but if you've ever been
down Lord's Lane my advice to its don't
go down it prior to occupation three
conditions away there it please has to
be considered before occupation doesn't
your common sense tell you but a problem
already exists every day you see the
consequences of nearly on every road of
parking and the problems they create we
should not be adding to it the parking
for these steps should become to be
considered in isolation because these
houses are part of the will be part of
the community local current coalition
should be considered as most need their
car to get to work the number of cars
will increase adding to the difficulties
of the local area to buses to strap the
Judaic isn't gonna make anybody give up
a car the MPPs
paragraph 180 discusses the effective
use of land and suggest the use of
minimum density standards and states
that the opportunity should be taken to
achieve net environmental gains over
development does not suggest an
environmental gain and finally the other
point I'd like to make look at our own
corporate strategy recognize
the needs of environmental improvements
with instantly surely well-designed
sensitive housing is a way forward and
this is not the way forward with
reproduction house as you can see in
kill him instead Stratford we're ever
asked this question and the potential
for future problems now I live in a 200
year old how long is that gonna go on
for 200 years or a week next Tuesday and
how will that be supervised and insured
over that length of time because the one
thing in my old house they still do that
they did too many years ago is collect
the bins so I think it's a consideration
thank you for your time thank you really
questions was that part of the district
council done all sorts of what they sold
all and we've got lots of applications
coming in locally for housing on old
garage sites yeah
I've dinner whether I should ask you
this but the application is 16 it's been
in sometime
has there been discussions with the
applicant at all
and he technical questions yeah Thank
You chairman two questions if I may
the first of all though there is there
was an appeal allowed on this site that
was back in 1996 which obviously that
has expired but nevertheless it was an
appeal that was allowed and was this on
the same access as this one and the
second question is are there any other
developments in the district which have
private bin collections thank you
you want your absolute corrective detail
in the report this site was subject of a
aloud appeal in 1996 that was for three
dwellings it's my understanding I
haven't unfortunately got any visual to
show you it's my understanding that the
same at this point was indeed the pose
for that appeal as it's now being
proposed for this application before you
that is my understanding of the previous
site and that's your first question it
I'll see a second question on waste
collection management strategies in my
experience and perhaps I've benefited
for each of its two comments at any
point I would say that these type of
strategies are not uncommon for urban
areas whereby there are logistical
issues relating to waste collection be
it for matters of impacting on any
potential listed properties and whatnot
and potential tight roads and access
points so in my experience a waste
collection management strategy is not
uncommon to have but secured by way of
condition in my experience
well um I'm concerned about this in the
respect that both the world member and
the parish are united in the respective
reasons for refusal they are obviously
bland and and we can't really go against
the County Council when approving the
entrance but my thoughts really would be
to defer it but I wonder what other
people thought so
all the console tees support it or they
don't object to it yet the Parish
Council have a number of objectives the
opposite way so it's one of those if we
go against it II could go to appeal and
we could lose the appeal but we
shouldn't talk that way I know but the
problem is all the console tees have no
objection I think that's our problem
without I'd be happy to defer it for a
site visit so we could see the entrance
properly because it does look very
narrow but with the attendee council
saying they have no objection what will
we achieve George why does it may give
us the comfort which we want but you
cannot ignore the previous appeal have
we a proposal and a second per site
visit
hmm cancer brain cancer Atkinson who
proposed to Cyprus it oh I've got to be
and we will have a vote on a site visit
and then we will not have a vote on the
approval or refusal all those in favor
of a site visit or a me against one
against we should be having a sybers it
and it will be adjourned to the next
meeting that's the access and the number
of points bought out by the parish
council and also I think design is
another factor in the Greenbelt we move
on there to the next application 18
stroke Oh two one three one stroke fall
I leave the office here to go through
this when you've got it up or found it
all right there we go the application
site is identified by the black dot on
the map and is located in the heart of
the village of Sanborn the application
is curtilage is identified by the red
outline on the plan in the property is
known as the old post office it
overlooks a village green which is
located here and lies within the West
Midlands Greenbelt and also the Arden
special landscape area as shown in the
Purple Line it also lies within the
conservation area the application site
has a split garden one which lies to the
rear and one which lies to the side
adjoining the property is an as a
separate one called
a green dragon cottage who doesn't have
a rear garden they have their entirety
of their amenity space is towards the
front to the side I guess is of their
property here the application sites
sorry the area of development is
concerning this area here and Planning
Commission is being sought to erect a
single-story
garden studio which is effectively to
the side of the existing house to the
south and the existing site boundary the
Planning Commission is required because
the development doesn't constitute
permitted development because of its
position and the building will sit on a
frame that is five meters by 3.8 meters
in an area but the actual structure
itself will be four point seven meters
wide with a depth of 3.2 meters and
overall height of 2.5 it will also
incorporate
Samana pitch roof and doors the front
elevation with windows to both side
elevations is proposed to be constructed
with water in words with tunnel iced
redwood honey stain coloring colored
cladding and with graphite gray windows
and door frames and finished with a the
roof will be finished with olive green
kingspan composite panels the proposed
garden studio would be located 20 metres
away from the existing house I just want
to remind members really why we're here
is in terms of policy cs10 of the core
strategy which sets out the policy for
developments within a green belt in
order for it to be considered for a
curtilage outbuilding to be considered
small scale a small scale extension to a
dwelling and thereby appropriate
development it must comply with the
development considerations of the policy
of one of which is that it says that a
new dwelt curtilage building ie a garage
should be within 5 meters of a dwelling
this is obviously 20 meters away the
other considerations are obviously
explained in the report in detail
turning now to have a look at the
photographs this is a view of the
property so looking at the corner of
weic weick Lane she's not showing the
frontage of the property as it wraps
around the corner and the outbuilding
would be located within this part of the
garden here this is a slightly further
down on the road so you can see the site
has a relatively open nature by having
this existing hedgerow and trees behind
this is looking opposite now this is
white lane looking opposite existing
vistas and then this is inside the
curtilage itself so the building will be
positioned behind these two trees here
you can see the existing boundary
fencing surrounding the property there
is a garage belonging to the adjoining
neighbors behind this is again just a
closer look within the garden itself
you'll see the existing boundary
treatments and this is the adjoining
neighbor's garage so there is no updates
to report in chairman the recommendation
is to refuse for the reason as detailed
in the committee report Thank You chair
thank you very much
I didn't notice that the parent council
support this application and aren't here
the ward member has made no comment we
could have probably have delegated it
but I will ask the board member to speak
now and we will continue as the officers
doing their presentation one of the
things are very always felt to have to
adhere to with the principles laid down
about the green belt and I still believe
in those and the issues that can contain
conservation and other things so that
bit of me we're saying you've got to do
what the policy's advisors but then the
other bit of me was saying well what
harms are going to do it's not really
gonna do any harm nobody will see it
properly and it's going to affect the
way people live because we all like to
improve the way we live and this is part
of that process so in the end and I'm
sorry you felt about this councillor
Barnes I felt it really needed the
wisdom of the committee to make the
decision
about whether it should be fused or
should accept what the applicant is
actually saying so can I leave it with
you thank you are there any questions
for the number no thank you very much
thank you are there any other locations
that this studio could be in that would
not be considered to be harmful to the
Greenbelt Thank You Jay yes we have been
in discussions with the applicants and
strongly suggested that the development
be sited in the rear of the property and
also by doing so that it would actually
fall into permit a development if it
would if it were within five meters
which was to bring it within five meters
of the dwelling and in doing so comply
with policy the policy on Greenbelt in
which circumstance it would be a small
scale extension to and therefore not in
appropriate development the applicant is
declined to do that
I remember a wonderful but looking at
the photograph it's quite a Welling
clothes gone so chemically seen from
neighboring properties or from the open
countryside of the green bow I know
that's not a reason to go opposite to
what you're saying but there's two
elements the assessment of the Greenbelt
is whether it's inappropriate
development or not the character of the
Greenbelt where is that the policy in
terms of small-scale development and
that kind of thing is more a matter of
principle irrespective of how visibility
is from any public view so there's just
that delineation to make the
recommendation of office is firmly in
the camp of it's inappropriate
development whether it can be seen or
not officers are fully aware that it's
well screened from the road and the
exceptions to the only exception would
be if there were very special
circumstances to outweigh the harm to
the Greenbelt
just just go back on what you were
saying just basically saying because
it's in the Greenbelt there is no way
that we could go against the decision to
refuse it is that correct you need very
special circumstances to outweigh the
harm what would those special
circumstances be the design or I can't
lead Committee on what they might be all
I can say is look the law says they
can't be easily repeatable and they must
therefore be very special but they
haven't put any reasons
oh just a quick comment is that I'm dead
agreeing this sort of thing being
prevented by the green bill but on the
other hand if there's no no special
circumstances I fear we have got to go
with the officers recommendation anybody
else I'm caught happy to do in the
respective there has obviously been
discussions there is other sites which
are acceptable and they've not been put
forth so if that was a proposal I'm
quite happy to second refusal yes I'd be
a professor already the boat refused
Eliza's the officers recommendation all
voting - against abstentions okay thank
you very much now let the new chairman
okay thank you so now we are on to 1802
one two three the coach-house Hanlon
Arden and Charlotte Thank You chairman
the site is indicated on the map by the
black circle the application site is
located to the north of Henle and Arden
and cited to the west of the Birmingham
Road it sits within a small cluster of
buildings known as Beaudesert Park which
are outside of the settlement and washed
over by the West Midlands Greenbelt this
slide shows the application site edged
in red the site consists of a one and
two-story dwelling on the southern side
with a large walled garden to the north
to the south is a great T listed
building known as boh desert park
indicated by the red building the site
shares its eastern boundary with the old
dairy a residential property open fields
are but the site to the north and east
with a track also to the east and a
public right-of-way is seen to the west
of the site indicated by the green line
this is an application for approval of a
single-story
outbuilding which would provide a
gymnasium shower room craft dream and
storeroom the siting of the building
would be would result in the demolition
of part of the historic wall which is
shown by the dotted yellow line the
building would be sited over a destroy
over 50 meters away from the dwelling
the slide shows the out building in
relation to the other features in the
area the historic wall is believed to
have been the walled garden of the main
house Beaudesert Park which the housing
development was named after informed
from again the historic wall is
indicated by the yellow dotted line
these plans show the proposed floor plan
and how the building would be sited
within the historic wall which is
visible either side the outbuilding
would measure 7.2 meters by 9.8 meters
and 2.8 meters in height this plan shows
the proposed elevations of the out
building which would feature facing
brick and a flat roof with two gable
features on the front elevation
this photo shows the historic wall when
viewed from the south standing with our
back effectively to the coach-house and
facing towards the north the approximate
location of the outbuilding is indicated
by the yellow rectangle this photo is
taken from the opposite side of the wall
now facing south again the approximate
location of the outbuilding is shown by
the yellow rectangle this photo is taken
from near to the wall facing north
towards the open countryside showing the
open boundary treatment this photo is
taken from the approximate location of
the outbuilding facing south towards the
rear elevation of the caged house just
to clarify there are no updates officer
recommendation is to refuse the
application for full planning permission
for the reasons on page 76 of the agenda
thank you chairman thank you very much
and now we hear from the parish council
councillors David Broadbent and David
Tomlinson okay thank you very much as
you probably know three minutes and I'll
tell you when you had two and a half the
original conversion of the outbuildings
and the renovation of the house was
around 1977 with a comprehensive
remodeling of the structures in 2012 the
officers report to committee in 2012
concludes among other things that the
designer materials are in keeping with
neighboring properties and that no
harmful impact is caused by to the
visual amenity of the area the proposal
in front of the committee emcompasses
the same style and materials and does
not impact on any neighboring properties
it cannot be seen by any other property
the report concludes that its
development in 2012 constitutes
appropriate development in the Greenbelt
and would not result in harm to the
visual immunity of the Greenbelt no
mention is made of the wall nature of
the garden or the fact that sometime
prior to 2012 application a significant
part of the western section of the Ward
had been reduced to almost grown
presumably as a result of the cost of
repairing a 2.57 meter high single brick
wall as part of and since the major
works of 2012-13 this wall has been
maintained in a more than satisfactory
manner by the applicant notwithstanding
the fact that it is not listed per se or
curtly it's listed as part of both Beau
desert Park estate it seems clear
therefore that to describe the wall as
holding heritage significance is not
necessarily correct and it is not been
considered at heritage asset by those
who carried out the listing exercise in
1972 otherwise it is readers reasonable
to assume that it would have been
included in that listing your office has
also concluded that the purported harm
caused by the proposed construction is
considered less than substantial the
wall forms part of the boundary - and a
visual barrier from within the
substantial gardens of the Coach House
given that it is not listed in itself
and does not form part part of the
Beaudesert part listing there will be no
there would be the potential to take all
of them all or part of the wall down and
open up the vista encompassing the
remainder of the garden the applicant
has no intention of doing this and
merely wants to project the new
structure through the wall the
projection is relatively insignificant
in comparison to the wall and could be
made even less obtrusive by careful use
of materials in the construction of the
roof and walls benches within the
committee's remit to condition any
consent in this regard the couch ASIS
and it's Curt lease is washed over by
the West Midlands Greenbelt in a
settling of development and
redevelopment of vertical agricultural
buildings and the mansion house the
proposal is an individual building in
the garden setting of the dominant
property substantially screamed from
Oakland countryside and from the listed
property and in the opinion of the jpc
and the bureau's officer does not harm
the openness of the green belt or the
Arden special landscape area perfect
thank you very much any question just
councillor organ
can you tell me where the the 19 2012
approved relevant history is is that to
the Coach House itself yes it's not for
a separate building in the grounds no
thank you catch that concern I'm
thinking there is no public right-of-way
within the vicinity of the application
there isn't is one to the south but it's
nowhere near this I think we can ask
that to officers
counterfeiting any other question nope
thank you very much
and under technical so now the applicant
are Lawrence Marshall
okay and as you know you've three
minutes and I'll tell you two and a half
minutes thank you I'd like to give the
committee some additional background
information on this application before
addressing you to the areas where
non-compliance of policies relates the
report mentions the previously approved
application from 2012 the coach-house
was a tiny 2-bedroom farmers cottage
that's that's unoccupied in a state of
semi dereliction on a plot of land just
over an acre
neither the cottage nor the wall itself
is listed a careful plan was put
together to create a modest and
habitable three bedroom property
utilizing the specific 30% allowance
that existed at that time as per the
report the percentage figure was deemed
to be approximately 1% over the
prescribed figure and permitted
development rights were removed by
conditioned hence this press application
there are certain very special
circumstances that need to be considered
in this application firstly when looking
at the volume in considering policy cs10
in its latest form section 4 point 1.9
makes it clear that the previously
applied 30% maximum threshold was
unreasonable and that going forward a
more appropriate way of maintaining
openness would be to consider proposals
on a case-by-case basis yet in its
conclusion the report still appears to
touch disproportionate weight to
percentage volume figures while showing
little if any evidence of a case-by-case
analysis so percentage figures aside
what we're referring to in this case is
creating an ancillary and ancillary
facility to the bed to the benefits of a
modest
three-bedroom dwelling to give this some
sort of visual perspective the new
building would sit on less than 2.5
percent of the plot and within the
courage of Beaudesert Park which is in
itself a dense cluster of buildings
within the Greenbelt secondly when
looking at the proposed location to the
building policy CH tends development
management consideration
say the new courage building should be
within 5 meters of the dwelling
however the detrimental impact on the
remains of the form form carbonyl garden
setting the combat in complying with
this desire create an exceptional
circumstance to do others otherwise
and finally when looking at the
historical garden wall we need to view
this within the context of the walled
garden as a whole rather than just a
single snapshot of the wall
the committee will benefit from the
start of image 1 which is in front of
you now which shows the view of the wall
in a westerly direction and you can see
that the whole of that elevation was
reduced to a height of less than a meter
and cups we slap back as early as
nineteen sixties early seventies the
view to the left of the proposed
location that's correct there shows the
impact of the existing ad buildings on
the wall and as was mentioned if
necessary approval could be conditional
upon the green metal roof fell had
buildings being removed thereby giving
back the same amount in fact more of the
actual wall twice at the same time
achieving a vast improvement in the wall
gardens overall visual appearance we've
tried to take great steps involve the
architect team following through the
line of the wall and taking every effort
we can over the years to actually
improve the condition and thank you
thank you very much now you touched on
very special circumstances there because
I mean there's two aspects of the
refusal one is some heritage which you
mentioned and one is green belt which
you also mentioned I said I think as a
very special circumstance you were
raising the point that it's a very small
percentage of the the plot 2% or
something of the plot I got that and
then you mentioned detrimental impact
when you were talking about it not being
five meters from the house which would
mean you could get it under green belt
sort of as an extension you said that
would have a detrimental impact on the
wall or something else yeah can you
explain that to me I miss that if we
look at the if we look at the whole
concept of a walled garden to play
something within the five meters of the
place would be I think there are as you
can see the main twenty five shooting
city the outline of the wall we're
trying to do all our best to actually
restore the integrity of the okay so
it's it's a I get that point now and and
you offered to remove the existing
outbuildings as you pointed out okay
thank you are there any other questions
councillor braid place the I think we
heard from the previous speaker
some of the arrow yeah along that
elevation there the the wall as it stood
was sort of leaning over and being
dragged over by the by the trees so yeah
okay counselor fielding it's the
proposed I think for private use private
okay any other transfer fielding okay
can you turn your and Hawkinson and you
are preserving the walls appearance by
not having too much of a structure
coming from it into the value of the
area which was your amenity factor I can
see in terms of that right it otherwise
you would have something which may look
completely different and what you're
trying to do there is preserving the
integrity of the entire setting great so
there are far easier options and the
options we've chosen we've chosen an
expensive option that is quite difficult
but he gives you regard and you respect
the integrity of the wall and the gun
thank you very much no more questions
thank you Kearney thank you and now
cancer third world who has five minutes
Thank You chairman I would just like to
emphasize at the beginning that the wall
in question is not listed at obviously
nine reads for house when the applicant
upgraded the property in 2012 he also
decided that where the wall had
collapsed on the west side of the wall
garden to rebuild the wall in a modern
style that had been there previously as
they're also aware the research
refurbishment and extension of the
original cottage fell foul on the 30%
rule being 1% over on that system that
was in place at that time which had
resulted in permitted development rights
being withdrawn and the reason why we're
talking to you this evening yes the
application lies within the Greenbelt
the principal aim of Greenbelt is to
prevent urban sprawl
I would suggest there is little chance
of urban sprawl in that part of the
country the question that needs to be
asked is what his proposal is harmful to
the Greenbelt the applicant is already
stated that the proposal would sit on
less than 2.5 percent of the entire plot
and is it within the curtilage a budget
park which he's also stated is a dent
cluster of buildings the remaining part
of the wall was still easily
demonstrated it was originally a walled
garden I would also point out there be
no objections and indeed a lack of
support for this application I would ask
you also to note that the applicant has
offered to remove the green metal
roofing roof building which he says will
vastly improve the overall appearance of
the walled garden as I said in my
original response
there will be no detriment to neighbors
and that is a welcomed facility in this
health and conscious day and age Thank
You chairman thank you any questions
Canterbury
clear where would be the sighting of a
seal away the proposed outbuilding is
it's an area to the lab okay any other
questions no thank you very much
counselor and so we're gonna go to
questions to the officers I'm going to
start one can we if we chose to permit
this would removal of the existing
outbuildings which has been talked about
be conditional or requestable yes okay
and am i right saying that that can play
a part in very special circumstances
obviously it's the decision taken to
decide what he's very special but okay
now what it was mentioned that the whole
wall could be taken down without asking
permission is that comment on that yes
okay I danced this up any other
questions to the officers counselor
Kinston understand and some of the
comments actually I'm on page seventy
five one two three four five paragraphs
down the very last sentence this farm is
considered to be less than substantial
but there is no demonstratable public
benefit how would one expect to have
public benefit in a private dwelling
facility they
understand that well we've got question
counts yeah I'm glad you phrased that
counts of the there is an error in the
report in how that is framed usually
we're looking at a designated heritage
assets such as a listed building but
this is one of the few cases where it's
not a designated heritage asset it's a
non designated heritage asset so it's a
different paragraph of the MPP F and the
waiting's different so notwithstanding
what it says in the report
it doesn't need a demonstrable public
benefit to outweigh it what the MPP F
says it's much looser if it's a non
designated heritage asset you simply
have to weigh the harm against all other
planning matters so it's it's a much
lesser test in this case so my apologies
that the report is misleading in that
regard but the test is the reports
incorrect to say that you need a public
banana I've had their correction Thank
You councillor fielding I find it
difficult to deal with this one which is
in the green belt questions on this one
on questions did the last one which was
also in the green belt is there a
difference for us to grant this one
which when we refused the other one what
is the difference there's no difference
okay any other questions so to catch the
breaks I can't see if the wall could be
demolished it was quite a lot of weight
[Music]
yeah and that's because it could be
demolished but in all likelihood the
owners not like she's demolish it you
would have no cause to demolish it but
it could happen but that's a theoretical
one that's why that's why the weight is
given appropriately
okay I just another question we've got
two reasons for refusal here we've got
green belt which we would require that's
I think that's undisputable relatively
the green belt one it's inappropriate
development so if to grant it on that
count you would need very special
circumstances okay the listed building
one as I've just clarified if you
consider that there is harm and it's
less than substantial it simply needs to
be weighed in the balance against all of
the things okay so we need to consider
it okay thank you so can we go to debate
and yes cancer organ thank you
I can't see what difference in reality
it makes on this site which is not
within the public domain the applicant
is prepared to remove one building and
construct another which is probably
going to actually be more suitable for
modern living and what-have-you
I can't see what the problem is because
there will be no public harm and it's
not intensifying the number of buildings
within the area I think new for old
buildings come again
for people to look at from the house
although public view building on a
number of occasions I find the Greenbelt
very difficult to cope with
because I think development should be
allowed but I can't see why we should
allow it here when we refused it at the
last application it there is no material
benefit but in the when all gardens are
in existence they always had buildings
lent up against a big green houses being
putting sheds etc and if they had this
sort of design I think I don't see why
whether one could be more easy to
approve it than what he wants to do in
taking down part of the wall
Cantrell arkinson it's a well-known fact
you judge every application on its
merits this has a different dimensional
appearance and factor compared with the
previous one I can't see the parallel
there at all and I believe chairman the
proposal which has been made by the
applicant is very worthwhile I think
that could enhance the setting without
any doubt even though there is no public
access to it as one would basically
understand it if you look at stately
homes walls do have attachments of the
type slightly different certainly
there's a place called Warrington horn
in Northumberland where you'll see that
just go to pack wood house and try to
sleep over it and you'll find exactly
the same I just cannot see why there is
a difficulty with this one has got to
respect Greenbelt and heritage factors
but this does not interfere with the
principles of those policies
I hope chairman that members conceived
the validity of what has been discussed
in favor of it and support the
application against the recommendation I
would be happy to propose approval okay
thank you for that proposal
yeah I think yes the first one we've
heard has cancer Atkinson's we do need a
second that we need reasons to to
overturn the officers decision on
heritage which I think you've you've
talked about you've talked about other
other designs other other gardens with
similar we would have to we would have
to include that into into a condition
because it's not in the proposal so we'd
have to we'd have to condition that
removal of the existing building I'd
just like to comment on very special
circumstances which that we do need
because it is inappropriate according to
policy because it's it just is you know
and and therefore you do need for a
special circumstances you've got one
which was the removal of the existing
building so you know the overall impact
on the on the green boat is lower the
the applicant himself mentioned several
things that he could have built it
within five meters of the existing house
but he felt that would be more
detrimental to the heritage aspect of
the thing the fact that it's a very tiny
percentage area of the garden so is
small in that respect and that the
actual design within the wall itself is
preferable architectural and visually to
two to one which was inside the garden I
would suggest those it's very special
circumstances for your reason for
refusal and I second you on that in that
case yeah the only one of those I'd
maybe invite members to steer away from
is that the fact that
he could build something worse closer to
the house sure that's a very special
circumstance because he doesn't it
doesn't have to build this one but but
the others I suppose it yeah it would
just take design in the heritage aspects
in this particular design fine by me
ok with that then we go ahead so all in
favor of granting this application ok
thank you so this committee has resolved
grant so we've got one condition which
is the obvious one based on what's been
if we could have members retaining
because we might have another vote on
this I'm not sure yeah
obviously there'll be one requiring the
submission of a plan to show which
buildings are to be demolished what the
overturn was and then the others would
be the standard one's a three-year
condition approved plans condition
approval of materials the wall to be
made good in the area of where it's
built and everyone happy with that great
thank you very much
so we have resolved to grant planning
application 1802 one two three with the
conditions mentioned and business so
thank you very much everybody
so